you posted a video of you on the Sony
lot where you shoot the Goldbergs this
is a video of you walking around take a
look okay so I'm in my tighty-whities
says that you know on the show you were
you where the tighty whities on the show
how the tighty whities on the show
sometimes and I spend the entire day
what am I gonna be like false modesty
put on a robe all the time
no I got places to go I got to go back
to my trailer so I just do it you put on
a robe you put on her yes you put on a
robe no you put on a robe I'm not
putting on a rope
look I just danced I'm upset about that
but wait so so I won't be on the lot
yeah I go I walked I was walking to the
coffee place I'm a lot so I've been
lying with people in my underwear like
also there's your money by my wiener all
right no I don't I don't eat in my
trailer i money with me I'm on the lot I
don't need any money I just go Jeff
Garlin they are you that was them giving
me coffee
yeah it's that big of a cup that's a
terrible space work throw your improv
background here's your coffee
as your puppet here's your ancient
musket
I don't know what you're doing well I
don't know you're just you got a line
stuff up here's your here's your coffee
that's the size of the property market
and then you hand it off okay now what
barista blows on your coffee Jeff Jeff
uh americano Jeff yeah that's me oh my
and also my barista knows exactly how I
like but beyond that beyond that this is
how your barista this is actual liquid
would have been like this all right okay
I guess we all agreed none of us are
good at wrapping object work okay so it
began with my underwear all day
there's tours I ride my bike around in
my underwear I don't do it I'm not
showing off by the way let me just say
it started off with I don't like tighty
whiteys I'm a boxer guy write briefs all
right all right I remember we live
together right nice to see you all the
time and you were in boxers you never
wore tight you didn't walk around naked
out for me no no no you didn't I
wouldn't come by your door hey Cohen
what's going on yeah dude
although it's funny to do that no so so
the first the first show first episode
they have the Goldbergs Goldberg's
Wednesdays ABC they I'm in like the
underwear and then like the the people
for the censors are like oh we see
movement we see shadows next time next
episode they double it up you know two
pairs of underwear pairs of underwear we
see movement we see shadows the next
episode ferritin yeah well I don't know
and then they put like a material that
like being my knee pad of like a
football thing like soft but yeah yeah
yeah yeah so that's there now there
ain't no movement and there ain't no
shadows but they still come in we see
movement we see shadows I'm like enough
this is as far as I go
and by the way the only way you can see
shadows if they put a flashlight behind
my balls we see movement we see shadows
one it's just one older lady who comes
in there and she by the way
she probably he's that everywhere tip I
have looked less cool than dancing I was
an old guy from a bar mitzva dancing
early now the old man no no no I love
that we followed that by showing you in
your tighty whities resolve this in
black shoes I'm just I'm really
vulnerable with your odds I trust them
yeah you trust them yeah people huh
[Applause]
you